hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to so much to certain
noise is that something important
probably not okay forget why you don't
need to be such a pessimist about things
you can do it believe in yourself you're
a rule oh my god is that bubble coming
to rescue me oh I miss you that buh buh
buh buh buh buh bye so it's boobie vine
oh my god I can't believe why am i
turning into a hillbilly oh my god
bubble butt you're here oh okay oh oh
bubble butt came back for me
I'll find a way ah thanks bubble butt
you're the best oh my gosh are you gonna
be following me around now oh you're so
cute I love your bubble but always will
like I said you're my little bubble
blowing bubble bug biscuit oh you're so
cute okay alright then I guess I'm going
into theta now I might be oh no I'm
going into Delta or night but don't I
need to get to theta first I'm not
entirely sure Oh
Bubble Boy you're the best you're my
little buddy following me around
oh my god it's whole army of bubble
butts these bubble butts don't look as
good though uh don't worry bubble but
you don't have any competition they are
a little on the sleepy side okay so I
could either I guess I could go into
here it doesn't seem to be going
anywhere and it's red blaring lights
again telling me that I need to go to it
so I shouldn't ignore that I shouldn't
be a fool hello
oh look at you excuse me sir would you
rub my crotch in your face stick my hand
in here still don't know how that's
doing for me giving me some sort of
electrical charge or something
I'm obviously draining power from it I
mean I'm assuming that I need it for one
reason or another hey babbit
hello alright so I am is here if i zoom
in I need to get to one of these red new
daddies and then go into the complex
over there and then do what I need to do
whatever they tell me to do okay let's
do that thing that I talked about doing
cool uh uh alrighty then
time to break my ankles hmm I'm okay
bubble but don't worry about me you
probably have a good time out here
swimming with the Robo fishes Oh bubble
buzz my little buddies following me
around
hufflepuffs ball hood me here out I
honestly didn't know if I'd ever see
bubble butt again
Oh bud Oh ain't you just a bubbly little
bud risu cute okay anyway back to the
actual game that I'm supposed to be
playing here I totally forgot that I
actually have a thing I forgot that this
is a horror game just cuz I'm too
consumed about bubble bud being here
oh man I haven't heard if there's a wide
variety of enemies in this game so I
have no idea always follow me they're
always trying to gets little lost in the
fence sometimes it's okay bubble but
everyone gets confused from time to time
he reminds me of something from fallout
actually you know I think there was a
similar type of thing and fallout but
I'm not entirely sure who can I go in
here would it be wise to jump down
bubble ball what do you think tell me
what to do now shall do it yes okay I'm
going in bubble but I trust your
judgment here we go
I can't okay I'm a family sure I can't
do the thing I set out to do oh well
that was interesting
hello hello little lotion flap-flap
how's it going there hey buddy how you
doing good to see you okay
so there must be another way in
you're not bubble bud bubble butt
protect me from the meanies protect me
from all the poopies unlike tiny box Tim
I don't think I could protect you uh I'm
certain that you must protect me hello
little guy well alright then goodbye
alright so this obviously is just going
back around the way I came so I'm
guessing if I see an enemy that's
probably pretty close to where I'm
supposed to be going I wonder if there's
gonna be anything oh how about the big
door hello wrong with you your legs are
splayed a little funny there I pross him
to be here that's a little weird okay
alright bubble but this might be where I
leave you I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to go open this thing
buh-bye oh you're the best Thank You
Bubble Boy I love Bubble Boy hey bubble
bud
bye bye buddy good robot good robot good
bubble boy alright bye bye bubble butt
oh wait maybe I am I'm not leaving you
huh seems like there's a bit of a
problem over here
seems to be some sort of infestation
from this cancerous robot huh ah yep
again there's no explanation from the
character as to why that's happening or
what it's for I mean I highly doubt that
it's a safe point probably something a
bit more sophisticated than that hello
oh it's Bubble Boy
hey bubble but lacks a voice module is
able to communicate via simplified sound
and lights bull ain't so fun
that one I don't know what that is okay
the vessel is basic intelligence only a
pilot is needed to fully utilize its
good there's one it says it's remote
piloted so I'm not entirely sure if it's
entirely independent but it might be
okay teri it's been decided that you and
your crew will evacuate to theta on the
14th everything is being taken care of
you will be given all new positions as
you arrived last thing we need is more
leaders [ __ ] you I'm not going anywhere
you don't have the authority to make me
stop taking my jab this isn't my orders
you idiot I'm just a messenger you want
to say I can buy you some time if you
want to hang out at your dump but your
crews moving tomorrow I'm happy to
inform you that your crew has arrived
safely at theta let me know when you're
ready to move in I'll send transport
don't hesitate to ask me if you want to
be relocated to theta apparently someone
wanted to help someone but someone
didn't want help okay login login login
Terry anchors one is a thousands game of
chess good for you Terry Akers Jess oh
wow Oh
corrupt opponent come on now well fine
then be that way maybe that would have
worked if I hadn't had rained that thing
and then there would have been something
there but who knows maybe maybe not
all right we're a delta we just need it
it's a short hop to theta so it
shouldn't take that much longer
Lisa hope not anyway and there seems to
be some sort of tunnel that does lead to
there so if there's nothing else that I
need to find what Beth hello is Terry
Akers in here need some robot assistance
on his poopit
of my hand into there because I sure do
have a disposition of shoving my hand
into dirty places okay never mind then
bye bubble butt I'm back baby
come along bubble but we've got more
exploring to do so there appear to be
like red lights and then there appear to
be the light blue white lights
and there appeared to be a bubble but
slight I'm talking about the eyes on
enemies that I've seen so far I mean I
have seen Hemmings that have oh I
wouldn't have noticed this bubble boy
probably for the best not sure I trust
the show train okay
well find that if you just want to be so
pessimistic about it you don't hear
nothing you don't see nothing you're a
blind idiot so you are nope all right
can't believe how much I'm sweating in
this suit okay
the signal
okay so his green lines assuming I need
to rotate to the line oh oh god I gotta
got it hello
it was on the default one that it was
already on who's there
okay what's the point of this okay
hello anybody there
okay so let me try the other one pink
monk Oh for nine am I supposed to
remember these numbers I don't know this
is actually important for me to do two
one six oh four nine person oh four nine
two one six four nine two six eight 4004
nine two one six eight 4004 nine eight
4008 4004 nine two one six probably not
important 8:40 four nine two one six ba
ba ba ba ba
I'll always love you see you next time
8:40
one six eight forty oh four nine two one
six eight forty
two one six eight 4004 nine two one six
8:40
oh that's blood that's a lot of oh my
god are those eyes someone tore out
their eyes eight four nine wait no 8:40
no god dammit oh four nine two one six
eight 4004 nine two one six
hey 4004 nine two on six let's see the
light is hurting my eyes he's telling me
I don't need this hey Lily vitreous
flesh inside my skull to be salvation I
will gladly revenge them remove them
stop them from obfuscating the Dwayne
Johnson okay I don't know what the rock
has to do about this oh okay I guess I
could have done that that's a little
easier all right then I thought I needed
to ops you skate the Dwayne Johnson but
I'm not sure about that house annex I
believe Oh God is there something not
fun in that locker probably my
reflection in the black blood of our
warden whispers I need to save them from
this hell to beat them sleep luck them
in the lucid dreams I've seen see let
them sleep not beat them sleep don't
beat anyone sleep okay so there's that
then is this important
okay here we go it's exciting to watch
Wow claim Delta half a year ago I'd be
worried I'd have gone and one clean the
black blood from the machinery now it's
crusty surfaces seem to compliment even
outshine what built a was well good for
you you went mad don't look more chess
corrupt opponent oh come on
all right so apparently there's a guy
who's not having too much of a good time
in that locker over there and dude you
like your eyes back sir
Oh grody okay I guess that's it then
wow I thought that was gonna be another
reason for being here I thought that was
gonna be more but only is this the
scrawling z' of a madman before he
finally descended to the deepest level
he could go well alrighty then I guess
that's it okay alright bye then a lot of
exploratory stuff here I was sorry
hello once again bubble but how're we
doing on this fine evening time to
venture forth someone else 8:40 oh four
nine two one six still don't know if
that means anything so it's got to be a
way unless where does this are there any
is there another cable that might lead
out of this no this goes back to that
control panel I mean I would operate
under the assumption that it's supposed
to be something maybe I'm just missing
the dots here are you not gonna bother
me are you okay hey could you maybe help
I need to get the thing give me some
really no listen
make yourself useful Hey can you hear me
give me some food really listen OOP
stand there you know better what do you
mean I know better than that you don't
know anything hey can you hear me make
yourself useful
I'm trying to make myself useful I don't
know exactly what I'm supposed to be
doing okay here's another door I think
I'm gonna miss this one so maybe this is
gonna give me another clue
come on Thank You bubble bud
thank you you're delightful darling all
right so hopefully in here there's gonna
be another answer to what I'm supposed
to be doing cuz otherwise I'm very lost
and I have no idea what I'm supposed to
do oh well such is life bubble but
please do not get in the way I could
never be mad at you but don't test my
patience all right what do we have here
another dead man oh I can actually touch
this guy sorry right you saw Akers
[ __ ] and checking that [ __ ] into them
he got me pretty bad
I think I mean it worse pulling away I
can feel it bleeding out can you see him
[ __ ] he got on a Zeppelin he's going
back to theta we have to warn them
good luck with that the platform radio
is dead
remember the Boomer annex should work it
has to yeah you go I I'm not gonna make
it I'm just not come on Evans you have
to want to co-op
well alright then so Akers the chess
champion has gone rogue and done bad
things so what I have to do is I have to
figure out a way to get all this
organized Zeppelin colonel [ __ ] you
Akers invalid command okay so it's got
messages Akers is doing some strange
[ __ ] he just took the Zeppelin back to
theta
don't let him doc shut it the [ __ ] down
oh you didn't even send it come on man
all right hurry a map zoom in okay so
I'm assuming that what I need to do is I
need to make that the communications
antenna connect with its target which is
spa probably supposed to be theta
right now it's pointed at the green but
maybe needs to be pointed somewhere else
what's this
hello all right here we go shipping
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba okay Zeppelin's
request tens 400 that's it Oh 490 forty
and two one six okay so I just got a ah
so what I got to do is I just got it I
got a hook it up 204 nine and then
request a transport because it's sitting
idle that's what it said okay this makes
more sense that was easy to overlook
that would have been very easy to miss
that was just a terminal that wasn't
even lit up very light because there's
lights everywhere so it's not exactly
obvious which light is the right light
well four nine okay 10-4 good buddy
ba ba ba we're gonna get out of here
but if I start calling you Wilson then
you might want to question my sanity
okay point Zeppelin Oh for incoming baby
that's way awesome antenna signal
strength is good okay cool that's cool I
didn't know that antenna was for the
Zeppelin's that makes more sense
ah okay that ain't good stress key you
can see the Zeppelin now good sorry
about the mess without the positioning
system the stems just keeping a
separates Bolton did sandy could've
picked up your suburban to give me
antenna it's just met Adele you know
just me going clear because instead of
being a stubble lid alright happy happy
happy stew maker sir can you hear me I
hear you Terry I mean mr. Akers sir I've
changed my mind
I would like to come to theta let Delta
sleep of course Wow
honestly didn't expect to hear from you
again such a long time since you kept in
we have a few divers in a Zeppelin's for
being lambda at the moment I'll just
make sure they pick you up where they're
done thank you for the warning I'll make
sure they feel welcome when you get here
so who's best - laughs maniacally to
yourself when you're setting your evil
plan in motion
hello I am I about to be rescued could
you please Catherine I did good oh we're
safe oh it's really disconcerting
popping in and out of existence like
that where are we now Delta at least
that's what you said before the crash Oh
of course is this a Zeppelin
appropriately date you think you can get
us to Thea it's a cargo transport they
use them for moving materials between
the sides anything that's too big for
the shuttles I'm sure it can carry us
okay
good man why won't it work come on Oh
the tooltip is bust isn't that part of
the omni-tool look who's been paying
attention you back it up salon then you
know how it works we need to get a new
tool chip and switch it okay
care to point me in the direction of the
closest tool ship storage I think it
would be easier to just take one from
the roba
what just knock a robot over the head
and steal their chips the tool box over
there says it has a stun baton you could
use that come on I don't want to hurt
anyone is this a bit much it's just a
robot Simon we're just robots
zoria I'll get the chip I am NOT
knocking out a bubble but I am NOT
knocking out bubble what no I ain't
gonna do it no way no how
yes I'm not sure she's a stun baton I do
have a choice I feel awful the robots
only appear intelligent they're much
more like dogs than humans I wouldn't
hit a dog sorry poor choice of words I
don't want to hurt anything well we
needed to chip or or stuck here we need
a tool chip from one of the robots you
should be able to knock them out with
the stun baton you picked up I'm not
gonna knock a bubble but I'll knock out
that other human-like robot before I
knock out bubble butt no no no no no no
no way no way knowing hey buddy hey hey
buddy
this won't hurt a bit probably maybe I
know you're probably a human
consciousness in a shell but frankly I
like bubble butt more than I like you
cuz you didn't even want to talk to me
unless there's another did you up [ __ ]
on [ __ ] Casey we need to test that one
before me
oh I think all choice ethical dilemma
there's no way bubble I'm not knocking
out oh boy man I just say we can keep
things classy even when women are around
you know what are you tipping your
Fedora to me milady mmmm-mmm I Robot
Berube oh man and be so douchey to do
that yeah yeah you so full of [ __ ]
random I've seen you in payload manager
Alice Koster shows up buh-bye I
literally can't hurt bubble what I
formed a permanent bond I'm sorry this
is just their way is okay don't you run
away from me
I feel like a bad man Oh combine hearts
mmm they feel bad but please bubble but
still here no bubble but don't run away
from me bubble but no but I'm sorry I
had to know Bubble Boy ha ha ha it's all
horrible
I didn't want to do that oh really
needed action
we'd be stuck here did you do it killer
robot like that I get attached to them
too I'm not a monster but in this case
it had to be done he was talking I mean
it was delusional but he seemed sincere
present yeah well I'm sure it's fine was
he really that different from us it's
just beginning to sink in
I mean really sinking
I'm a robot did my cover this already he
said no one ever since I woke up a time
salon just keep suppressing it but my
brain doesn't want me to think about it
it's really getting hard not to think
about it yeah could you maybe hit that
switch over there so would you do moving
oh yeah sure
thanks Catherine is this gonna be like a
would you kindly situation bubble what's
afraid of me now or not never heard
Bubble Boy ahh sucks god damn it
Oh bubble butt please forgive me bubble
butt oh I forgot to hit the button sorry
how can i betray him I mean I didn't but
still hmm he was afraid of me that's no
good I don't like you Catherine
now like you men been busy I've got
nothing to say I really have nothing to
say I'm just sad I didn't want to have
to kill that guy or machine or whatever
it is that this ethical quandary wants
me to consider oh man we're just going
into the blackness aren't we so acres
went a little out of his mind apparently
and probably fornicated with a little
too much Robo food lettuce plate Delta
detour but we're back on track thanks we
should touch down on a cargo platform
just outside theta then we just head
inside grab the duck back and head down
the abyss 4,000 meters that's a long way
we don't have to worry though because
with the dump at the art could have been
in the Mariana Trench no hope for
anything thanks Amy
then we can start listening to other
people when they dock because that's how
conversations work what oh sorry
which is kids not thinking about what we
could come it's clear that we're no
longer human but then how can I feel
like Simon how can I feel like anything
at all I mean technically I don't have
any ears no mouth Christ it's a good
thing to think about I mean I'm making
sounds I'm still saying things you sure
okay your new body most likely has
senses similar to those you had as a
human and your mind only knowing one way
to perceive the world superimposes that
skillset on top of your new features so
my mind is covering it up pretending
nothing's different if it didn't you'd
probably be incapable of interacting
with the world at all and the stress
would either kill you or make you go
insane so I've found a good balance
between awareness and ignorance does
that mean I shouldn't think about this
stuff or are my thoughts actually making
me cool could I tip the balance by
suddenly gaining some in sizing and go
insane I wouldn't worry about it I mean
we have real things to deal with saving
mankind remember speaking of which we're
closing in on theta I'll eject V on the
tool as always don't forget to take me
with you
what if I did before you go the
artificial intelligence you mentioned
give me a skinny vessel uh-huh yeah the
warden unit the Wow
is it the wows fault that we're like
this I mean it seems like something an
unreliable AI would do
I suppose it set the ball in motion but
it's not direction was purpose it's
really complicated to explain how
machines thinks
concentrate on getting inside data okay
see you soon okay thank you Catherine
your insight is always so respected I
don't know it's a bizarre thing to think
about like all these things they're
talking about I was already thinking
about so I guess it just makes me
smarter than everyone else here no does
not at all I'm a complete idiot because
I mean boom but not trust me they're
debating their humanity and I'm just
worried about a machine liking me that's
all I care about good stress key wake up
dr. masters we'll bring it in Akers
what's wrong what can I say
is that a rough day so watch it by
stronger shrapnel about certain a number
on him Brandon flip the panic switch on
the sink I don't want to burn through
the oxygen you're kidding right what we
need to move
stress key get the infirmary ready we
need to move fast wait where are come
Arabian the others this is all we got
I guess it still it Delta stress ready
enough I'm coming in alright
without his bizarre who is with Akers I
thought a KERS commandeer the ship by
himself
the Zeppelin or whatever you want to
call it I have no idea what's going on I
am more lost than I've ever been
no bubble but two got me I saw this
light I had to come over here just cuz I
wanted to make sure there's nothing over
here but apparently there is not and I
wasted my time and everyone else's oh no
I didn't hello
maybe Christmas Catherine I'm busy
working oh I just wanted to say thank
you you did
don't worry about it but you should
stand up for yourself
I mean Schumer does I'm that kind of
authority you can just tell him to go
[ __ ] himself
oh I just don't I'm not that kind of a
person you can't expect people to fight
for you all the time you're a brilliant
person Cal you're so smart it makes my
head spin but sometimes you just
disappear into yourself suddenly it's
like talking to a [ __ ] five-year-old
it's just hard I can't just be more like
that everyone to know under tending it's
not too late to win people over Rosie
likes you
I like you Reid likes you stress Q likes
and everybody yeah that's true
wait using leave nice me Catherine a lot
of people like you you just need to open
up a little be more approachable can I
get to work now never not be reprimanded
twice in one day
okay see you back at slide over now well
alright then
so Catherine is a timid sore but that's
not totally shown by the Catherine that
I'm traveling with Catherine seems like
she's not necessarily as timid as that I
wonder if there's other small things
like that that I've missed what is this
over here
Thank You Catherine wait
am I already here hello hello mark
you're more right than you know we
haven't met before miss Kahn I think
we're safe oh I was so worried something
you've gone wrong what's your name
Robin bass a little flare clear mr.
Wilson
nice to meet you Robin how did you get
here
I got scanned like the others and then I
killed myself at least I think so I
can't remember that part how does that
work did Diane get you into the army
well you're definitely not from theta
let me guess Omicron wasn't sure
Catherine will be able to scare you guys
you're lucky there was a lot of talk
about this at theta the idea is when
you're activated in arc
there's basically two of you right one
human one living skin in arc you don't
want your copy to survive you you
yourself want to survive on arc if the
human you died before the scan is
initiated or closely after you yourself
would live on an arc amazing right oh
man Jimmy haven't put you up to this
killing yourself
Catherine ken no I don't think you
understand she just did scans and put
them into the arc I hope I get to meet
her soon so I can apologize she always
got into trouble with strong IO and
someone killed themselves I think she's
okay with this where is everyone
I thought there would be like 40 or 50
people here I don't know I'll let you
know if I see any Robin
I'm not sure how to say this what this
is pretty amazing right uh-huh mean New
York yeah it's great
Catherine and the guys have really
pulled through they saved us all
uh-huh they sure did oh this is a sad
situation I could pull the plug I mean
would that be ethical is it ethical at
all to pull the plug on this living
consciousness the only copy of this
person is here and yet there is a plug
that I could hole is it merciful to do
that is it like I see that some sort of
like this cancerous thing the WoW is
actually like it's commandeering living
tissue and whatnot to create power for
these machines it doesn't work I mean
the artificial intelligence is obviously
trying to keep these things alive no
matter what it's trying to keep
everything alive and trying to
accomplish the goal of getting everyone
into the arc sled weird okay like I
could pull the plug here and I may never
come back here
like what's the right choice here oh man
there's so weird there's so many choices
to make I almost feel like it'd be
merciful so stuck here alone in the
middle of the ocean oh it's not the
right choice is it I have no idea like
okay that's a little disturbing you're
talking right to me here it's not it's
not okay you can't mess with my emotions
like that you you should hang on I'm
thinking there's one thing that I know
in my heart that I would do I know I
wouldn't want to live like that no one
is
and the weird thought is that if the
power is somehow brought back she just
come right back and so bizarre that's so
bizarre man the whole concept that
people are so afraid of death that
they'll do literally anything to try to
prevent it even kill their self after
they've been copied not so weird it's so
weird so weird
ah the so bizarre all right actually
before I open up this door I'm actually
going to end this episode here thank you
everybody so much for watching I my
brain hurts my heart hurts I have no
idea if I'm doing the right thing or not
but I think that's the entire idea about
this game
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
okay all right
there might be something behind me okay
back out